den Fall drauf und wir gucken jetzt vor
allen Dingen noch mal auf ein Thema was
den Wahlkampf der ja in der Tat sehr
kurz war noch mal durcheinander
gewirbelt hat und zwar die
silvesterkravalle hier in der Stadt
danach war natürlich die Themen
Sicherheit und Integration noch mal ganz
anders in der Diskussion und wir
schalten dazu noch mal zu meinem
Kollegen Marlon ammoyal ins
Abgeordnetenhaus die hat sich das Thema
auf diesen Wahlkampf ausgewirkt
ja ganz schön Manifest denn die
Umfragewerte gerade für die CDU die
Stiegen nach der Silvester Krawallnacht
die hier in Berlin ja auch das
politische Tablet die Parteien hier alle
aufgeschreckt hat danach gab es auch
viele Forderungen wie man das Problem
angehen kann und dieses Thema ist ein
Thema was die Berlinerinnen und Berliner
interessiert sie hatten ja gerade schon
ganz viele andere Themen auch
angesprochen im Gespräch aber wir wollen
über das Thema Integration sprechen und
wir wollen auch über diese Westerwald
noch mal sprechen bei mir ist als
muschkowski er war Bürgermeister im
Bezirk Neukölln 1991 92 und dann noch
mal von 2001 bis 2015 ich habe es gerade
gesagt die haben ein Stück weit auch die
Stimmung hier in Berlin geändert
zumindest wenn man jetzt auch die
Umfragen sieht ist das das einzige was
sozusagen diesen Wahlkampf jetzt auch
noch mal deutlich dominiert hat
naja es hat Öl ins Feuer gegossen das
ist schon klar die Atmosphäre angeheizt
es war es ging ja auch zur Sache das
kann man ja nicht anders sagen aber das
ist es natürlich nicht allein insgesamt
sind die Berliner unzufrieden mit der
Stadtpolitik der Berliner senata die
schlechtesten Umfragewerte von ganz
Deutschland in allen Bundesländern und
da muss man sich nicht wundern wenn die
Leute auf der Straße auch Abwinken wenn
sie auf Politik angesprochen werden aber
richtig ist
Silvester war ein Höhepunkt der
Fehlentwicklung und es war eigentlich
nicht das was man sich den Alltag in der
Bundeshauptstadt vorstellt diese Sachen
gerade ein Höhepunkt der Fehlentwicklung
danach hat beispielsweise die Regierende
Bürgermeisterin Franziska giffe gesagt
ihre Parteikollegen und auch
Nachfolgerin ja in Köln sie packt jetzt
an man muss die Dinge auch jetzt beim
Namen nennen man muss verstärkt auch auf
das Thema Sicherheitspolitik setzen das
Integrationspolitik auf die Agenda heben
aber ist das ein neues Problem oder
nicht eigentlich ein Alters hier in
Berlin also ich beziehe das was sie eben
aufgezählt haben also das habe ich schon
hundert mal gehört das ist überhaupt
nicht neues das ist wie die obzidierte
Härte der Gesellschaft und das ist wie
jetzt müssen wir aber an klare Antworten
geben und wir müssen aber auch sofort
eine Gipfel einberufen und wir brauchen
unbedingt noch ein paar Sozialarbeiter
dass das nicht wieder vorkommt also
nehmen Sie mir es nicht übel das ist
alles hochgradig albern das haben wir
schon 100 mal gehört das hat an den
Verhältnissen überhaupt nichts geändert
und die sozialen Verhältnisse in den
Brennpunkten der Stadt sind absolut
dieselben wie vorher und sie werden auch
beim nächsten Silvester wieder so sein
wie vorher und dann wieder werden wieder
alle ganz entsetzt mit großen
Kinderaugen
die Kameras gucken und sagen na das ist
ja ein tolles Ding das ist ja das ist ja
eine völlig neue Richtschnur und jetzt
sind wir aber doch schwer enttäuscht
machen wir es mal ein bisschen konkret
weil sie ja auch die Erfahrung haben aus
Neukölln sie leben dort sie sind dort
auch unterwegs ich habe sie gerade
gesagt auch Franziska giffer war ja in
ihrer Zeit als Bürgermeisterin in
Neukölln nach ihm ja auch dort vor Ort
jetzt geht es konkret ja darum auch die
Probleme anzupacken die vielleicht auch
in den letzten Jahrzehnten will ich
sagen ja auch verschleppt worden sind
auf was kommt es denn da konkret jetzt
an braucht es mehr eigentlich in Bildung
braucht es nicht mehr auch letztendlich
auch Integration wirklich und braucht es
dann nicht letztendlich auch an anderen
an anderen Stellen z.B auch ein härteren
Staat also was wir mit Sicherheit nicht
brauchen ist ein weiterer laber Zirkus
äh das Ding kennen wir schon und
irgendeinen runden Tisch und irgendeinen
Gipfel das brauchen wir auch alles nicht
was wir haben wir haben soziale
Verwerfungen
im Miteinander der Menschen dieser Stadt
und diese sozialen vermerkungen müssen
wir angehen wir müssen an junge Männer
rankommen die sich totlachen über uns
wenn Sie irgendwelche
dauerkriminellen Taten begehen und dann
mit 500 Euro auf Bewährung das Gericht
verlassen da Schlachten die sich
scheckig und für die sind alle die eine
Uniform tragen ob hilft Sanitäter ob
Feuerwehrmann ob Polizist alles Feinde
weil es sind Vertreter diese Staates und
diesen Staat verabscheuen sie schauen
Sie ich kann Ihnen da Beispiel geben es
ist gerade ein junger Mann wegen
schweren Raubes und organisiert der
Kriminalität zu siebeneinhalb Jahren
Haft verurteilt worden was haben wir
gemacht wir haben ihn nach anderthalb
Jahren aus der Haft entlassen weil wir
eben die lange Untersuchungshaft nicht
zumuten konnte was hat der junge Mann
gemacht der ist zum Flughafen hat mir
geflogen und ist ab in die Heimat in den
Libanon sind sie so läuft das hier bei
uns und dann fragen Sie was sollen wir
machen damit die junge Männer von 20 bis
25 uns ernst nehmen ja wir müssen ihnen
einfach
entgegentreten und sagen wir sagen euch
mal wie hier die Spielregeln sind wie
wir miteinander leben und wir würden
Dich ganz herzlich bitten auch so mit
uns zu leben und wenn dir das nicht
passt dann musst du dir einfach einen
anderen bleiben also eine ganze Menge
auch letztendlich an Themen die hier der
auf auch Anforderungen der Politik
gegenüber ja sicher auch noch mal ganz
klar auch noch mal formuliert haben
jetzt ist man mit einer
sonderstaatsanwaltschaft herangegangen
es gab 155 Festnahmen es gibt über 100
Einleitung von Strafverfahren gegen die
Täter dort auch in der Silvester Nacht
sie haben es gerade angesprochen dass
das ein komplexes Problem ist und jetzt
gibt's aber auch beispielsweise in
Spitzenkandidaten der Union der sagt das
sind auch unsere Jungs also irgendwie
muss man ja mit dem Problem umgehen 35
36% der Berliner haben
integrationshintergrund wie konkret
anpacken was wenn ihre 123 Themen das
zum Beispiel brauchen diese jungen
Männer eine Lebensperspektive wir haben
20% junger Männer die die Schule ohne
Abschluss verlassen die haben keine
Berufsausbildung die haben keinen Job
die das einzige was sie haben ist
Langeweile und rumlungern und damit
kriegen wir sie nicht begeistert für
diese Gesellschaft und ich kann Ihnen
nur sagen also ich Bürgermeister war ich
habe mir den mundpuzzle ich geredet dass
das so nicht geht dass wir den Wagen
nicht so gegen die Wand waren lassen
können es hat niemanden interessiert und
solange wir uns nicht um die Bildung und
um den Bildungsstand dieser jungen
Männer es sind nur junge Männer kümmern
so lange werden die sich immer weiter
von uns abwenden diesen machen und sagen
die Herrscher dieser Straße sind wir und
nicht ihr und das sehen wir euch jedes
mal wenn Gelegenheit dazu ist und den
macht das Spaß denn Feuerwehrauto mit
dem Feuerlöscher einzuschmeißen das ist
den Verlust jetzt ist eine ganze Menge
wie gesagt auch was passiert ist sie
haben es gerade auch noch mal
geschildert glaube ich sehr plastisch
auch für die ZuschauerInnen Zuschauer
heute um 18 Uhr werden wir mehr wissen
wie die Prognosen hier sind was sind
denn ihre Erwartungen an diesen neuen
Senat der letztendlich damit der
Abgeordnetenhauswahl aber auch mit der
bezirksverordnung mit dem bezirklichen
die gewählt werden an dieser Stelle
dieses Problem anzupacken also ob es ein
neuer Senat werden wird man abwarten das
werden wir erst mal sehen also ich bin
da nicht so sicher wie sie weil die
Berliner sind da Leid geprüft und die
wählen dann auch das weiter und das
dritte mal wieder dasselbe auch wenn Sie
unzufrieden sind also ich wäre da sehr
sehr vorsichtig mit einer Prognose weil
die drei Regierenden Linksparteien haben
sich verabredet weiter miteinander zu
machen und rumzudümpeln als
alleinspielschar es wird aber nichts
Besseres rauskommen aber es wird so sein
dass sich die Menschen hinterher wieder
an den Kopf passen und sagen warum hat
mich keiner beraten warum habe ich den
gleichen Quatsch wieder gewählt aber es
stimmt eben nicht es sind alle gewarnt
aber wie gesagt die Berlinerin und der
Berliner sind leidensfähig und dann
werden wir mal schauen ob sie uns das
gleiche Geschenk zu Ostern wieder ins
Körbchen legen ich hoffe nicht ich
persönlich würde mich schon freuen wenn
wir einen Wechsel in der politischen
Landschaft Berlins bekommen würden
verdient hätte es die Stadt sagt ein
Berliner und sagt ein SPD-Mann sagt
Heinz buschkowski sagt ganz herzlichen
Dank für ihre Analyse